bonjour les invités de san roque a dit
ce matin catherine conconne la première
ferme sénatrice martin bonjour catherine
conconne bonjour allégorie bonjour aux
martiniquais qui nous écoutent
nous allons commencer par ce chiffre un
suicide par semaine en martinique et
cela touche particulièrement les jeunes
de 24 % sont des filles de 15 ans et
moins et 9 % sont des garçons ces
chiffres sont issus de reportage diffusé
sur notre antenne télé hier soir dans le
journal
en tant que femme politique en tant que
parlementaire est ce que cela vous
interpelle ses immenses est
époustouflant quand on entend ces
chiffres on se rend compte que si la
matinée qu'un progrès si dans six
indices par rapport à la prouve pauvreté
les éléments que l'on connaissait ya 50
60 ans où les gens étaient plongés dans
une grande pauvreté ou les épidémies
faisait des ravages à la menthe signé
aujourd'hui si ces indices se sont
améliorées l'état providence tentante du
mieux qu'il peut de compenser les
absences de solidarité eh bien on se
rend compte qu'aujourd'hui il y a
beaucoup de personnes qui sont installés
dans un profond mal être
alors il faut agir il faut agir au delà
des constats aujourd'hui il ya des
initiatives qui sont prises je félicite
ce qui se fait au sein de sos crise leur
présence est certainement des suicides
éviter des personnes écoutées pour
éviter de tomber dans l'or dans le fatal
il faut multiplier ce genre de ce genre
d'initiative
pourquoi pas installer sur les trois pci
les trois communautés de communes et
bien des cellules d'écouté téléphonique
de nuit de joe les ouvrir en particulier
aux jeunes il y à des expériences qui se
font ailleurs il faut donc aller voir
comment ça se passe et pouvoir les
ramener à la matinée en les adaptant
bien sûr à notre identité on a beaucoup
parlé de cyber-harcèlement notamment des
jeunes
comment agir parce que cyber harcèlement
c'est très personnel aussi oui il faut
travailler sur les consciences des gens
il faut dès l'école pouvoir expliquer
aux gens que nous sommes des êtres
humains avec nos fragilités nos
sensibilités et que poursuivre quelqu'un
sur internet
la dénigrer en permanence ex terrain
peut conduire à des situations fatale et
c'est une éducation je plaide beaucoup
pour que l'éducation nationale
anobli son corps plus le mot éducation
qu'il y a dans son appellation et ne
s'est pas et abyane au delà de
l'enseignement mais passent beaucoup de
temps à modeler nos consciences et à les
adapter un mode de vie qui est de plus
en plus difficile on a aussi
l'impression qu'il ya une sorte de
politique de l'autruche aussi sur ces
sujets de cyber-harcèlement
d'harcèlement maintenant ça se commence
à sortir néant l'impression qu'ils
avaient un moment une politique de
l'autruche qu'on voulait pas voir
vous savez dans toute société il ya un
moment pour découvrir des faits les
appréhender en prennent conscience et
ensuite agir donc tous qui resort
sociaux et tout ce sont des phénomènes
qui sont assez nouveau à la menthe signé
il ya beaucoup de gens qui ne sont pas
sur des réseaux sociaux qui savent même
pas de quoi on parle
lorsqu'on parle des ternes est lorsqu'on
parle la martinique est un pays où il ya
beaucoup de seniors qui sont à
s'éloigner de ce genre de pratiques
donc il faut que cette société prenne
son temps mais pas trop de temps pour
prendre conscience du problème est que
l'on puisse agir
il y a des moyens d'agir autre sujet
d'actualité fait la grève au parc
naturel la cgt mais ce md municipaux
entre dans la danse avec une grève à la
mise à la mairie de fort-de-france
quand on écoute le président du parc
louis boutrin c'est clairement votre
groupe ensemble une martinique nouvelle
qui est fautif vous auriez selon lui
jean gougy à tour de bras le nombre
d'employés est passé de 69 en 2010 à 174
6 je me suis bien en 2015 il oublie de
dire que le parc a triplé son budget que
le parc comptait en son sein environ 60
personnes qui étaient en insertion dans
un pays où il y à plus de 20% de
chômeurs et où plus de la moitié de la
population des jeunes est au chômage
comment peut-on blâmer une institution
qui a porté en son sein des contrats
aidés qui étaient payés par l'état et
qui permettait à des dizaines et des
dizaines de jeunes martiniquais de
s'initier aux nouvelles technologies du
développement durable de s'initier dans
des métiers qui vont être les métiers de
demain
moi je trouve que c'est un mauvais
procès lorsque le nom d'un personnel car
derrière c'est solide pour supporter ce
nom
de personnel augmentent il faut savoir
aussi que le budget du parc haïti
triplea pendant la mandature du
président daniel chomet qui a initié
énormément de travaux dans ce parc a pu
enfin ouvrir le domaine des maraudes qui
est très fréquentée qui était fermé et
inutilisé lorsque nous sommes arrivés
qui a mis en valeur un certain nombre de
pratiques telles que le mouton maquiller
le miel et caetera et qui portait à
l'époque le dossier unesco pour le
classement de la montagne pelée au
patrimoine mondial de l'humanité
c'est un mauvais procès moi je trouve
que quand on se dit président de tous
les martiniquais
il ne s'agit pas simplement d'afficher
son pouvoir de brandir le pouvoir est
l'espèce peut-être deux doigts de
vielles de mots qu'on pourrait avoir sur
380 millions indiqué il faut assumer
cette fonction
multiplier les espaces de dialogue moi
j'ai passé six ans à la région on n'a
pas une heure de grève chaque fois qu'il
y avait un préavis les gens étaient
écouter les gens a été invités à des
réunions et nous trouvions au tour du
mondial loeb
même lorsque c'était dur nous trouvions
des solutions pour éviter que des
martiniquais aujourd'hui ne s'affrontent
dans une ambiance que je trouve
particulièrement détestable et indigne
de personnes qui sont au pouvoir avec la
cgtm soem qui se mobilisent à fort de
france
est ce qu'il n'ya pas eu d'entente entre
syndicats ville de fort de france et lui
à belem au sein de la structure pour
faire pression mais ces messieurs je
vous signale aujourd'hui 26 mai ensuite
34 ont signé un appel au dialogue
il faut savoir que les maires finances
emilie finances le parc naturel régional
et à ce titre sont membres du conseil
d'administration
aujourd'hui il ya des membres de ce
conseil syndical qui sont dit mais à qui
sont pas du tout membre de pml il ya des
maires de droite il y à des mères de nos
peuples à qui son pote de proches de non
politiquement et qui demandent cette
comprend comment peut-on à longueur de
journée vouloir toujours écrit mines et
l'autre et ne jamais pratiqué la remise
en question c'est une pratique que je
trouve détestable dans cette cdm de
toujours accuser l'autre de napa avons
fait d'avoir tout fait de ne pas avoir
bien fait et je n'ai jamais un moment
donné je mets ton miroir devant demain
sa tête pour pouvoir se dire mais au
fait où est ce que j'ai fauté il
arrêter cette politique de l'autruche
qui est de toujours chargé l'autre est
de ne jamais sont remises en remettre en
cause
il ne l'aurait il ne leur restera plus
bientôt qu'un invoqué le quément bois et
de dio que bon c'est parce qu'on les
ensorcelés qu'il ya des problèmes de
cette 7e peu de courage levant la tête
et assumons nos responsabilités en 26
nous poursuivons notre entretien
parlons des prisons on connaît la
situation trois suicides une situation
grave et froide d'insanités de et de
tentatives au moins deux mois
vous êtes rendus sur place vous avez
rencontré des syndicats participer à des
réunions mais vous êtes contre la
construction d'une nouvelle prison
ça fait dix ans que je travaille à
améliorer le quotidien de ses prisons
depuis dix ans je me suis dit que comme
on dit en créole nageurs paf le chien
est qu'à n'importe quel moment n'importe
qui peut se retrouver dans une situation
carcérale vous sortez d'un chantier noël
un peu en vous et vous fauché un joggeur
sur le bord de la route avec votre taux
d'alcoolémie et bien vous avez beaucoup
de chance vous autrement prison
autrement dit je répète comme on dit en
créole
la jeune parfaite coucher donc lorsque
je me suis rendu en commencé à
travailler à la prison au centre
pénitentiaire de ducos plus aucune
formation était dispensée à l'époque
lorsque nous étions au conseil régional
nous avons pris à bras le corps ce
problème remet la formation
professionnelle au sein de la prison
pour occuper au maximum les personnes
quittant détention mais également
améliorer le quotidien comme faire une
salle informatique améliorer les
conditions de vie lorsque vous êtes
enfermé pendant 24 heures vous pu loger
déjà votre peine et bien il y a des
questions à se poser et faire de ce lieu
de détention et de rétention de liberté
un lieu qui pourrait être un lieu de
reconstruction que parce qu'il s'agit de
purger sa peine
forcément le détenu se joue nation
qu'est ce qu'on fait à ce monsieur
population mais allégé un certain nombre
de choses qui ont été faites l'état a
rajouté 160 places quand je dis que je
suis content une deuxième grisons je
suis content
la réplique de ducos un lieu de
détention sec sans lien avec des lieux
de promenade réduite à une peau de
chagrin des cours pour la sortie des
prisonniers jeu qui ressemble à ce que
vous n'avez jamais vu
bon je suis partisan qu'il y ait une
autre structure géante en deuxième aux
visions maison de redressement mais
comme je peux dire maison de
redressement je mets des guillemets le
redressement n'est plus à l'ordre du
jour en matière d'éducation
mais imaginez un jeune qu'à 22 ans qu'à
24-24 comptant qui a pris 1 en prison
parce qu'il a commis une faute qu'il
faut qu'ils réparent il faut qu'il la
paye je suis partisan depuis auger sa
peine quand on a fait des bêtises
et quand on a fait du mal aux gens il
faut faire confiance entre les primo
délinquants c'est oui ma fribourg des
risques on pourrait pourquoi pas être
accueillis dans une structure telle que
celle que je vais visiter mardi à
villepinte dans la région parisienne où
par exemple il y a des codes 2
d'éducation qui sont remis à l'honneur
où il ya par exemple projet qui
s'appelle respecto qui permet à ces
délinquants de pouvoir se retrouver dans
une dans une situation de roy
construction pour éviter la récidive une
fois qu'ils auront purgé leur peine
je ne suis pas pour la réplique du cos
de la prison de ducos telle qu'elle est
mais je suis partisan de multiplier un
certain nombre de structures carcéral
prime d'art qui puisse en tout cas
s'adapter au mieux à la nature de notre
délinquants seraient peu de temps
vraiment parce que on a quasiment fini
alb yo ma le galion le conseil
d'administration a voté lamazou la
majorité le raccordement lusine diouma
s'en va dans le bon sens mais bien ça va
dans le bon sens je vous signale pour
faire un point d'histoire que
l'autorisation d'albi home a été donné
en 2005 le conseil d'administration de
la scène du galion a approuvé en 2007 le
raccordement
c'est pas nous qui tuons pouvoir
l'équipe les idiots cette somme à
l'époque quand il faut un peu se dire
qu'est ce qui s'est passé depuis dix ans
je rappelle que les qui croient pouvoir
en amérique rime critique sa cuisine
avant d'accepter une usine bagasse
charbon merci beaucoup catherine
conconne bonne journée a dit content de
nos programmes
[Musique]